zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
frieden wird nicht zwischen freunden
sondern zwischen feinden geschlossen
heute an einem tag wo wir in den nahen
osten blicken und sehen dass wieder
raketen hin und her geschossen werden
zwischen dem gazastreifen und israel ist
dieser satz von nizza kabinen aktueller
denn je
zwei die sich einstmals gegenüber
standen aber heute sagen wir müssen den
hass überwinden sind heute in unserer
sendung
einst waren sie feinde jetzt kämpfen sie
gemeinsam mit worten für den frieden der
palästinenser suleman khatib und der
israeli bunzel dessen eltern sind
holocaust-überlebende stammen aus ungarn
er selbst leistete militärdienst in
israel kämpfte in den achtzigern im
libanon-krieg mittlerweile arbeitet er
in einer it-firma und ist als
reiseführer tätig bunzl meldete sich
heute aus kreativen in israel
außerdem zu gast so jemand hat ihm seine
kindheit ist nach eigenen angaben
geprägt von vertreibungen und morden
durch die israelis er sagt nur noch die
gewalt als ausweg und lösung des
konflikts latif schloss sich der vertrag
an warf steine und verbrachte
schlussendlich mehr als zehn jahren haft
wegen einer messerattacke auf zwei
israelische soldaten ihn erreichen wir
in ramallah im westjordanland
tja und einige jahre später ist er einer
der mitgründer von kompetenz hobbys eine
organisation von palästinensern und
israelis die sich ohne gewalt für eine
friedliche lösung im nahen osten bei
einsätzen herzlich willkommen ja ihr
bunzel und suleman hat schon dass sie
beide heute abend mit in unserer sendung
sind und herzlich willkommen liebe
userinnen und user macht mit schreibt
uns schreiben sie ihre fragen und
anmerkungen in die kommentare oder an
die eingeblendete e mail adresse wenn
sie die app nutzen
wir werden heute den nahost konflikt
nicht lösen und wir werden auch nicht
alle fragen klären können die mit der
aktuellen situation zu tun haben aber
wir möchten darüber sprechen welche
lösungsmöglichkeiten sie sehen und vor
allem was sie an den punkt gebracht hat
zu sagen wir müssen aufhören und zu
bekämpfen
suleman lassen sie uns mit ihnen
beginnen erzählen sie uns von ihrem weg
erzählen sie uns den weg vom
steinewerfer der vertrag zum mitgründer
von combat ins hobbys danke dass sie
ihre gäste sein dürfen heute abend das
ist ein ganz besonderer augenblick über
unsere wege unsere geschichten zu reden
denn es wird gestorben
in gaza im augenblick und ich muss der
realität ins auge schauen wenn wir über
sie reden
als ehemaliger kämpfer war ich im
palästinensischen widerstand seit beginn
der besatzung da war ich 14
ich war dann politischer
häftling und das hat man leben natürlich
geprägt aber ich habe meinen freund
kennengelernt damals schon und habe
damals schon erkannt dass gewaltfreiheit
mehr macht und mehr chancen hat für
unsere freiheit und unseren frieden
manchmal war ich 14 tage lang mit
anderen im gefängnis zusammen und durch
das zusammensein haben wir überlebt aber
auch durch hungerstreiks und so kam ich
zu dieser schlussfolgerung wie einige
meiner israelische wir haben beide
erkannt dass es keine lösung gibt für
diesen konflikt nichts nachhaltiges
dieser konfrontation muss im interesse
der menschen zu einem ende kommen
ja ihr auch sie sind mitglied von
combatants for peace was genau hat bei
ihnen den ausschlag gegeben zu sagen wir
können diesen konflikt nicht mit waffen
lösen
ich war schon erstens guten haben
danke für diese chance mit euch hier zu
sein
ich bin aufgewachsen in einer familie
die sozialistische war und habe nie den
eindruck gehabt dass wir trotz dieser
konflikt mit der arabischen welt und
insbesondere mit den palästinensern
die möglichkeit haben werden in der
zukunft mal frieden mit mit unserer
feinde zu zumachen aber ein unterschied
bei mir vom sagen wir ziehen ist und
glauben an an frieden in der zukunft zu
eine aktivismus in eine palästinensische
israelische bewegung hat erst vor etwa
fünf jahren angefangen als mein kontakt
zu zu palästinenser auf persönlicher
ebene
als besonderes in jeden tag täglich und
intensiv geworden ist erst als ich
wirklich dass das alltag erlebt habe und
eine enge kontakt zu den menschen
sondern palästinenser als menschen wo
wir einander einfach kennen gelernt
haben und die familien kennengelernt
haben um den alltag kennen gelernt haben
das wird für mich eine angewendet
punkten ab diesem punkt konnte ich nicht
einfach auf eine theoretische ebene
bleiben eine zukünftige lösung eine
diskussion über politik und unwahr und
um parteien und alle diese theoretische
dinge sind sehr konkret geworden nachdem
ich wie gesagt die die die palästinenser
auch eine persönliche ebene können
gehört habe und von diesem punkt an
konnte ich nicht einfach bleiben als
sagen wir einmal in 2 34 jahren zum wahl
zu gehen und ab und zu ihren
demonstrationen teilzunehmen sondern
sondern ich habe es war für mich klar
dass ich etwas sehr engagiert mehr
engagement brauche und seitdem bin ich
aktiv in den konkurs verwies nun haben
sie beide ihre religion sie haben beide
ihre geschichte ihre traditionen
familiengeschichten und wenn man sich
anschaut sie sind nur ein paar kilometer
auseinander
also eigentlich gar nicht weit
voneinander entfernt aber doch trennen
sie gräben durch das was in dieser
region passiert sie kennen sich beide
durch ihr engagement vor für combatants
vps was verbindet sie miteinander
julia schilly man gerne beginnen sie
bitte danke ich spreche leider nicht
deutsch
meine familie hat er hat sozusagen als
eingeborene immer gelebt klar man redet
über die trennung weil das system will
dass wir getrennt sind und inkompetenz
for peace glauben wir dass für uns
engagiert sollten miteinander und
miteinander arbeiten sollten und dass
wir anerkennen dass wir vieles gemeinsam
haben und auch unsere zukunft ist
miteinander verknüpft und die beziehung
zwischen palästinensern und israel ist
auch eng verknüpft als ehemalige kämpfer
wissen wir dass der kampf uns nicht zur
lösung bringen wir müssen einen weg
finden um das system zu ändern
und ganz ehrlich diese art apartheid zu
beenden
denn die zwischen juden und
palästinensern
die ist die wurzel allen übels und wir
haben eine gemeinsame sache und wir
haben uns entschieden gemeinsam zu
kämpfen uns zu engagieren und bitten
auch unsere israelischen alliierten
sozusagen mitzumachen
nicht dass sie genau wie wir ticken sie
haben ihre religion ihre überzeugungen
und so weiter aber wenn man heilung will
da muss man anerkennen dass der andere
eben auch da ist und dann gemeinsam nach
vorne schauen wir was ist ihre antwort
was verbindet sie beide aus ihrer sicht
also ich bin 100 prozent anführt dann
denn mit julie mein freund von ramallah
und aktivist wie ich ihn komplett an
zombies diese apartheid und
diskriminierung und rassismus dass die
israelische regierung leide mit
unterstützung von von ländern die sehen
sich als als freunde israel und glauben
dass wenn man ein freund von israelis
dann kann man nicht gleichzeitig auch
ein freund von anderen menschen sein die
auch diese
leben nämlich die die palästinenser
dieses system ist nicht ist nicht normal
und ist eine unnatürliche situation man
man beton immer nur was juden und araber
juden und muslime menschen im gegensatz
zueinander haben und ich sage immer wenn
ich leute sehen leute es egal von
welcher religion von welcher farbe oder
von welcher rasse
ich beurteile diese leute durch ihre
werte und nicht durch ihre angehörigkeit
zu dieser religion oder zu dieser
tradition oder zu dieser
staatsangehörigkeit leute die die werte
haben wie freiheit menschenrechte haben
mit mir mehr in gemeinsam als leute die
die ähnliche religion oder tradition mit
mit mir teilen das ist nicht was mir ein
freund macht oder ein gegen gemacht wo
wir zu zudem gleiche dna oder blut oder
oder rasse die sind dinge die die zu mir
nichts spricht nichts
das ist für mich kein kein ebenen wo ich
meine freundschaft oder meine wenn man
mein gegner finger sondern welche werte
wir miteinander haben und die werte die
ich mit mit manchen moslem und manche
christen kann kann größe um tiefer sein
als mit leute die zu meinen religion
wurde angeregt ein volk angehörigkeit
das heißt wir erleben hier
gemeinsamkeiten über religions- und
staatsangehörigkeit grenzen hinweg aber
genau die gibt es eben bei vielen
anderen nicht weshalb die zeichen die
wir im moment aus dem nahen osten sehen
eher auf eskalation und aggressionen
stehen wir gucken uns die aktuelle lage
mal an axel sturm über das was im moment
im nahen osten passiert
wir treffen svetlana hofft soffin
schutzbunker
der schock sitzt noch tief es war wie so
oft in den vergangenen tagen knapp hier
in hallstatt 15 kilometer vom
gazastreifen
entfernt es war ein lauter knall zu
hören alle waren unter schock ein junge
hat geweint und gesagt ich will nicht
sterben ich will nicht sterben ich habe
ihm gesagt dass wir nicht sterben werden
dass wir hier nicht in gefahr sind
es war sehr furchteinflößend zum glück
waren wir hier wir hätten auch in
unserer wohnung im zweiten stock sein
können manchmal haben wir es nicht
geschafft
svetlana sie hofft auf und ihre kinder
haben überlebt dieses mal an diesem tag
der raketen terror der hamas geht weiter
tag 8
die antwort des israelischen militärs
ebenso hinter den kulissen wird
verhandelt die usa russland ägypten
angeblich gespräche auf hochtouren
wir arbeiten intensiv und versuchen ein
ende dieses konfliktes herbeizuführen
präsident biden hat mit einem netten
jahre gesprochen und mit präsident abbas
allein es gibt keine anzeichen auf eine
waffenruhe
im gegenteil auch im westjordanland
gewalt zwischen palästinensischen
jugendlichen und israelischen
sicherheitskräften
die hamas hat erst am abend angekündigt
erneut raketen auf tel aviv abfeuern zu
wollen
der an der stelle ganz kurz ein blick in
den chats und schon mal vielen vielen
dank für die rege beteiligung ich sehe
es gibt viele userinnen und user die
ihre meinung und ihre fragen dort
stellen und eine möchte ich auf greifen
weil wir hier ein bisschen kritisiert
werden gerade auf youtube apartheid
fragezeichen rassismus fragezeichen
geht's noch das sind natürlich harte
worte die aber in diesem konflikt von
verschiedenen seiten auch immer wieder
geäußert werden die ja ihr eben auch
geäußert hat eine sehr spezielle
sichtweise auf die dinge
was im gazastreifen passiert und wir
werden versuchen im lauf dieser sendung
aufzudröseln
welche rolle welche partei spielt und
wie man am ende etwas finden kann was
eine gemeinsame lösung für alle sein
könnte zudem an die bilder die wir
gerade im beitrag gesehen haben die
jungen männer im gazastreifen die steine
werfen erinnern sie sie an sie früher
erkennen sie sich da wieder und wie
bewerten sie das
die leute können doch die begriffe
benutzen die sie wollen das system
israel betrachtet nach unserem leben ob
in gaza oder auf den westbank oder egal
man lebt in dieser situation man darf
auch nicht zu den wahlen gehen nicht
mitwählen
das war seit 48 nie an dass die leute
können es nennen wie sie wollen
entschuldigung wenn ich das wenn ich da
kurz unterbreche ich hoffe sie können
sie können mich hören ich würde gerne
versuchen keine politische diskussion
mit schuldzuweisungen zu führen die
erleben wir nämlich hier im deutschen
fernsehen wirklich zuhauf mit
schuldzuweisungen wann wo wer wie
angefangen hat wen zu unterdrücken ich
weiß dass es ein thema und darum geht es
aber ich würde gerne bei ihrem
persönlichen erleben bleiben und aus
ihrer persönlichen erfahrungen die eben
gezeigt hat man kann dinge überwinden
versuchen konstruktiv zu schauen
wie kann man etwas
dann nochmal also die frage wenn sie
sehen damals die jungen männer die
steine geworfen haben
damals sie die steine geworfen haben
heute die jungen männer die steine
werfen wie kann man konstruktiv vorgehen
ich möchte einfach alle daran erinnern
dass diese dinge schon so lange in der
vergangenheit begonnen
diesmal hat es ihn gaza begonnen huth &
invest jordanien auch wir dürfen eines
nicht vergessen
wir leiden unter der situation
wir wollen die feuereinstellung die
wünsche ich mir schnell wie möglich klar
aber dieses business as usual kann es
nicht wieder geben
wir müssen nach vorne schauen aber wir
überleben wird das nächste jahr die
nächsten zwei jahre die politiker
versuchen immer den status quo zu
bewahren und das wollen wir nicht als
kompetent vps wir möchten den zweiten
weg der auch zu den wurzeln des
konflikts führt mein freund hat es an
bedeutet menschenrechte gleichheit für
alle das sind unsere themen die werte
die jede community hat auf
selbstbestimmung und das ist ein
längerer kampf aber der einzige weg
eigentlich auf dem wir auf die einen
sagen konflikt die anderen sagen krieg
die wir das beenden können wenn sie über
politik sprechen sprechen sie dann auch
über die rolle der hamas die man ja auch
in bestimmtem licht betrachten muss denn
die raketen die aus dem gazastreifen
abgefeuert werden in diesen tagen
fordern israelische opfer wenn man
versucht den graben zwischen ihnen
wieder aufzureißen
also quasi die familien von yahoo
[Musik]
ich weiß jetzt nicht auf dass die frage
war die frage war die rolle der hamas
sie haben das gerade so dargestellt als
wäre quasi israel ein aggressor und das
problem für das was im moment in der
aktuellen situation zu sehen ist ich
weiß sie haben einen sehr dezidierten
blick auf die dinge und dazu gehört auch
die rolle der hamas welche spielt die
und wo müsste sich die palästinensische
seite bewegen um eine veränderung in die
aktuellen prozesse zu bringen
vielen dank dass der eigentliche
konflikt ist 100 jahre alt
fast hundert jahre alt und es kommt
immer wieder zu solchen katastrophen
aber eigentlich gab es alles das schon
lange bevor sie überhaupt hamas gab
das war 1987
der anhalter konflikt führt zur
radikalisierung und gewalt aber wenn wir
von gaza reden gaza ist unter ständiger
belagerung
das darf man nicht vergessen das
argument dass die hammers betrifft ist
meiner ansicht nach nicht mit einem
gebührenden respekt nicht so relevant in
diesem kontext was ich mir zu sehen
wünsche ist dass die israelische
regierung sagt wir haben das recht zu
leben
und dann haben wir die verantwortung mit
unseren internen problemen fertig zu
werden und so weit ist es niemals
gekommen
deswegen okay sagt diese verhandlung
gegeben oslo und so weiter aber dass
sich die eigentlichen themen des
konflikts comcom buttons for peace hat
15 jahre die erfahrung gemacht
in partnerschaft und nicht die eine
seite die alles kontrolliert und alles
plant dass man dann weiter kommen kann
wir sollen uns um gemeinsam boden
bemühen auf dem wir partnerschaftlich
nach vorne arbeiten können und im grunde
für uns combatants for peace ist das
kernproblem einfach tatsächlich wir
reden ganz offen darüber
die israelis und die palästinenser in
unserer organisation
viel weiter gehen als die symptome mit
denen wir jetzt fertig zu werden haben
wir möchten sie entgegnen möchten sie
das ergänzen was ist ihre sicht auf die
dinge als israeli ich bin der meinung
dass wie in jeder konflikt man kann
nicht erwarten dass das die ganze
verantwortung auf eine seite legt und
eine seite wird als als engel
beschrieben
ich will nicht anfangen zu erklären und
erzählen wie seit 100 jahren diese
konflikte entwickelt hat aber wenn heute
man die situation sieht es gibt eine
unvorstellbare situation wo auf der
israelischen seite zivilisten
angegriffen werden auch der
palästinensische seite zivilisten
angegriffen werden in gaza zählt man
über 200 tote über 1200 verletzte von
davon sind 59 kinder ums leben gekommen
mit der ganze technologie und artillerie
und
luftangriffe ist sehr ungleich bahre
angriffe von einer seite auf die andere
ohne zu sagen dass eine recht hat beide
methoden weiter seiten benutzen methode
wo sie schießen bewusstsein auf
zivilisten benutzten waffen der nicht
gezielt sein kann auf die leute soldaten
oder oder münchen mitmachen erkannt wie
wir sie nennen wollen
aber zu dieser situation gibt es ein
sehr ungleiche kritik auf die seiten die
solche methoden benutzen hamas wird er
kritisiert israel wird kaum kritisiert
und ich sage nicht dass der ganze schuld
auf israel liegt oder auch hamas aber
ich würde erwarten von länder nicht
starke einfluss auf der situation im
nahost wie deutschland und andere länder
ihre einfluss zu benutzen um diese
situation zu beenden ohne zu sagen die
haben recht oder die andere haben recht
und das ist genau wie sowie gesagt hat
ist was wir seit 15 jahren im kommen als
für brice praktizieren nicht an schuld
auch der eine auf der anderen seite zu
werfen und nicht ständig über die
vergangenheit zu schauen sondern immer
zu suchen wege zum dialog ohne dass man
sagt ich verzichte auf meine narrativ
und du muss man akzeptieren das ist
genau das was ein user namens blauer
punkt hier auch gerade schreibt leute
ich sehe hier sehr viele kommentare die
die schuld einer seite geben
beide staaten sind sozusagen schuld es
gibt keine richtige seite beide haben
recht das ist also quasi genau das was
sie gerade gesagt haben ja ihr weil sie
das angesprochen haben mit der
internationalen
mit dem internationalen engagement was
lösungen angeht die hat es in der
vergangenheit her auch gegeben und wir
schauen mal an welche versuche es gab
frieden zu schaffen und was daraus
geworden ist frieden im nahen osten bis
heute konnte er nicht erreicht werden zu
unterschiedlich sind die positionen
trotz etlicher ideen da ist die
zweistaatenlösung sie ist so alt wie der
konflikt selbst das hauptziel zwei
staaten die friedlich nebeneinander
existieren
mit der gemeinsamen hauptstadt jerusalem
doch wie könnte diese aufgeteilt werden
wo verlaufen künftige staatsgrenzen
welches rückkehrrecht haben
palästinensische flüchtlinge und vor
allem was geschieht mit den israelischen
siedlungen im westjordanland viele
offene fragen obwohl die hoffnung schon
groß war geweckt durch das osloer
abkommen von 1993 unterschrieben in
washington
die palästinenser unter der plo
erkannten das existenzrecht israels an
im gegenzug bekam sie das recht auf
selbstverwaltung doch 28 jahre später
ist die realität eine andere
tja ihr die hamas hat eben das
existenzrecht israels nicht anerkannt
muss man dazu sagen was ist denn aus
ihrer sicht heute ein realistischer
lösungsansatz
es gibt unterschiedliche sage ich mal so
technische lösungen zwei staaten
konfiguration und so weiter und so fort
und ich bin der meinung dass die noch
mal wie ich vorher gesagt habe was
wichtig ist ist nicht zu welche fonds
angehörigkeit oder religion
angehörigkeit sondern welche werte
teilen wir oder arme miteinander und das
ist das gleiche die werte die wichtig
sind ist dass jede lösung egal wie wir
das auf der karte zeichnet und wünsche
technische untertitel und
details geschrieben werden die werte die
prinzipien sind wichtig die prinzipien
sind das die die lösung und die
diskussionen müssen gewalt losgehen
die lösung muss auf gleicher ebene
unterschrieben und entschieden werden
beide menschen um beide völker haben
hier genau das gleiche recht hier zu
leben im sicherheit in freiheit und in
gleichberechtigung und das ist das sind
eben die die prinzipien wenn man diese
prinzipien behält dann ist alles
eigentlich nachher weniger wichtig wie
das genau die ich nicht unterschreiben
und auch der karte zeichen das ist nur
eine ahnung
dann gebe ich die frage weiter an
suleman verbunden mit einem kommentar
von einem user namens elon musk von dem
ich ausgehe dass es nicht der echte elon
musk ist was wäre ein lösungsvorschlag
der aktuellen situation mit der die
lehman und ja ihr zufrieden wären zu
lehmann was was schlagen sie vor
also ich kann dir nur zustimmen
der weg zur lösung muss gewaltfrei sein
der weg zu lösen es wichtig nicht das
endgültige ziel
wenn ich denke wie das in berlin gewesen
ist
oder an anderen orten es hat immer
modelle gegeben in der ganzen welt gibt
es orte wo es solche konflikte gab
müssen gerade schottland ein
es gibt immer wieder solche probleme und
die wurden immer wieder gelöst
und wir dürfen nicht davon ausgehen dass
dieser konflikt ewig sein wird oder
nehmen wir bei irland
auch dort gab es bös konflikte aus denen
können wir etwas lernen
und ja er hat gesagt wir müssen
verständigen auf grundsätze und dann
kommen die praktischen lösungen auf wir
sehen dass brasilien man das bild
eingefroren ist das soll uns jetzt aber
gar nicht irritieren denn solange wir
ihn hören können ist das ja schon mal
was ja ihr warum scheint es in der
region so zu sein dass es viele menschen
gibt deren angst vor dem frieden größer
ist als die vor dem krieg
wenn ich das wüsste ich glaube wir sind
insbesondere in den letzten jahren ich
kann mehr von den israelische seite
sprechen
wir sind in einer situation wo die
regierung die die heutige regierung seit
mehr als zehn jahre in die regierung und
seine leute um sich herum bauen auf der
jüdisch israelische seite ängste die ich
mich nicht erinnern kann seit meinem ein
ganzes leben hier israel als ich
aufgewachsen bin in den 60er jahren war
die holocaust noch frisch in der
erinnerung von von von menschen aber die
regierung und die erziehungssystem
schulsystem und die media hat die
holocaust erinnerung nicht politisch
benutzt wie es in der letzte sagen wir
zehn jahren politisch und zynisch
benutzt und man baut ein an angst von
den
von den menschen auf der andere seite
man hat die riesige mauer gebaut man
trinkt die leute dass sie damit sie
einander nicht kennen lernen
richtig es war ein konflikt schon vor 30
40 jahren ich kann mich erinnern als
kind noch noch konflikte und
auseinandersetzungen und kriege zwischen
israel und arabischen israelis und
palästinenser aber wir haben wie die
andere nicht als als als als dämonen
gesehen das war ein konflikt das war ein
streit aber wir hatten den eindruck dass
auf der anderen seite sind die menschen
die wollen ebene wie wir und in der
letzten jahren baut man politisch ein
angst und ein trennung zwischen den
menschen und damit macht man die chance
für zukünftige frieden immer kleiner
das ist meine meinung ja ich würde gerne
nochmal zum ende des gesprächs gemeinsam
in die vergangenheit blicken und zwar in
die familiengeschichte der familie
bunzel wir haben ein foto was sie uns
geschickt haben und vielleicht können
wir das mal zeigen und sie können uns
erklären was man dort sieht wenn man
dort sieht wir sehen das foto ist eine
familie und wen sehen wir
wir sehen hier meine mutter als zwei-
oder dreijährige kleine baby auch shows
ihre ihre mutter meine großmutter links
und recht ihre zwei ältere bruder meine
mutter heißt judith aber alle nennt sie
bis heute sie ist 87 jahre alt heute und
immer noch wird sie baby in der familie
genannt sie sitzt auf dem schoß ihrer
mutter meine großmutter links unrecht
ihre zwei ältere bruder unterseite ist
mein mein opa bilder ungarn und ich an
bewusstsein dieser familie das ist
gewählt weil das sind einige jahre dass
sie mit der 30er jahre in budapest
ungarn und wir sind alle was ist
passiert einige jahre später in eine
immer
in andere länder in europa und aus
dieser kapitel in unserer geschichte
habe ich den unterricht gelernt dass wir
als menschen so lange wir die
möglichkeit haben gegen unrecht uns zu
bewähren um zu sagen dass es unrecht und
damit bin ich nicht einverstanden und
ich muss laut sagen das ist unrecht und
das ist meine unterricht aus diesem
kapitel in unserer geschichte
suleman die familie von ja er hat den
holocaust überlebt sie sind nach
palästina emigriert sie haben sich eine
existenz in israel aufgebaut
sie haben im gefängnis wenn ich das
richtig gelesen habe schindlers liste
gesehen und das hat für sie alles
verändert wir deutschen blicken immer
sehr besonders auf diesen konflikt im
nahen osten weil es eine besondere
verantwortung deutschlands gibt für
dieses land israel
was ist aus ihrer sicht die rolle
deutschlands und welche verantwortung
trägt deutschlands in diesem konflikt im
nahen osten
danke ja ich habe schindlers liste
gesehen und ich freue mich so dass ja
jetzt familie den holocaust überlebt hat
aber die wahrheit ist die viele von uns
sind ja panik auf europa und wir denken
dass sie nicht die richtige haltung
beziehen
auch wenn sie von verantwortung reden
dass sie nicht dafür eintreten etwas für
den die beendigung dieses konflikts zu
tun
nicht so wie sie es sagen
viele menschen haben den eindruck dass
europa auf einem auge blind ist
aber wenn sie mich fragen wenn deutsche
und israelis freunde sein können wie wir
das manchmal sehen dann erfüllt mich das
auch mit hoffnung dass auch wir
vielleicht guter nachbar sein könnten
oder gute freunde
wir müssen einfach die palästinenser
auch anerkennen und ihr recht auf ein
freies leben unsere familien sind seit
jahrhunderten auch hier besatzung und
besatzung um besatzung bis zu
israelischen besatzung und wir möchten
die menschenrechte anrufen und uns alle
europäer richten und sagen helft uns in
unserem bestreben nach selbstbestimmung
und freiheit der ganze nahe osten wird
davon profitieren
und ich sagte es vorher trotz dieser
dunklen zeiten die wir jetzt sehen und
erleben müssen was alles sich vollzieht
im augenblick bei com buttons for peace
behalten wir den blick auf diese
wirklichkeit wir erkennen sie auch an
dem sie zur kenntnis aber versuchen
darüber hinwegzusehen
ein leben in würde in respekt in achtung
vor dem anderen und wir glauben dass
kommt dann auch irgendwann und wir
werden es noch erleben ja ihr auch wenn
viele sagen würden diese frage kann man
nicht stellen die kann man vor allem
keine holocaust-überlebenden stellen
oder jemandem der aus einer
familiengeschichte kommt die das
miterlebt hat sie doug lässt schreibt
über youtube seit jahrzehnten zahlen die
palästinenser für den holocaust für den
sie nichts können ja ihr das ist ein
satz der trifft ins mark aber den hört
man oft und den höheren auch sie sicher
nicht zum ersten mal
was antworten sie es ist heute 100
prozent richtig und ich habe jetzt seit
zehn minuten mir überlegt soll ich diese
frage stellen oder nicht und ich bin
sehr froh dass die frage von oder seite
gekommen ist
dann ist damit ist meine frage
geantwortet ist jahrzehnte lang ist mir
diese frage nie zu kopf gekommen erst
vor einigen jahren habe ich plötzlich
diese frage klar wie die sonne vor mir
gesehen habe
das ist ja die einzige der beschreibung
der situation nach dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs die vernichtung von millionen
von juden in europa hat dazu geführt
dass die palästinenser den preis hier in
palästina später staat israel den
palästinensern bezahlt das ist einfach
die wahl wenn ich von von hier an dieser
stelle insofern widersprechen möchte als
ich sage das ist die geschichte die für
sich steht aus der vieles andere
passiert ist aber das eine ist das
andere was heute passiert und das leid
der einen gegen das leid der anderen
aufzuwiegen ist unrecht wenn wir
versuchen das zu trennen und an der
stelle die dinge nicht einfacher zu
machen als sie sind sondern anerkennen
dass sie schwierig sind kann man dann
versuchen mit einem ganz einfachen
schlusswort was banal klingt aber was
vielleicht eine lösung wenn man es denn
vereinfachen möchte wäre zu sagen wir
müssen einander kennen lernen das ist
das was sie am anfang der sendung gesagt
haben wir müssen einander zuhören und
wir müssen versuchen der liebe mehr raum
zu geben als dem hass so lehmann ist das
etwas worauf wir uns am ende dieser
sendung einigen können
vielen dank wir vergleich nicht das leid
mit dem leid anderer da bin ich nicht
ganz einverstanden
jedes menschliche leid muss als solches
erkannt werden und hat seine bedeutung
ja ich sagte er ich bin optimist ich
glaube dann die gewaltfreiheit aber
unter einbeziehung einer glaube nicht
dass das reicht aus der sicht der
palästinenser weil wir unter dieser
unterdrücken leben
das reicht nicht dass meine mutter
oliven er darf auf der anderen seite
oder nach jerusalem gehen darf okay ich
bin die jerusalem geboren
wir müssen aber mehr anerkennen obwohl
das natürlich zentrale fragen sind es
gibt viele strategien für den weg nach
vorne um eine lösung zu finden mit der
beide seiten lesen können
das wird seine zeit fordern das ist gar
keine frage es wird ein langer weg sein
und deswegen setzen wir so auf diese
partnerschaft und wir bitten unsere
freunde in europa auch ein bisschen zu
uns zu stehen und anzuerkennen dass es
uns gibt und dass wir eine bessere
zukunft wollen für den menschheit für
alle seiten gegen das leid und nicht die
aggression unterstützt
was ist ihr ja ja ja erst los warze user
also feine wird diese diese lange
konflikt daniels beide seite sind wir
gibt es opfer von dieser konflikt aber
dieser konflikt und dieser krieg ist
nicht unlösbar
viele konflikte wie so nie gesagt hat
angedacht sie werden nie gelöst und dann
plötzlich haben wir gesehen finden leute
menschen finden die lösungen finden den
weg wenn sie wenn sie wollen uns so wird
es auch eines tages in dieses in diese
dieser krieg in diese
auseinandersetzungen und ich bin 100
prozent an verstanden mit soli europa
kann und ich bitt und ich hoffe dass
europa und insbesondere in deutschland
eine eine wichtige rolle spielen wir
dass die viele deutsche fühlen sich
verantwortlich für die zukunft von von
israel
das ist das ist verständlich tro israeli
zu sein heißt nicht unbedingt dass man
an die palästinenser sein muss man kann
pro menschen seien die menschen die hier
in diese in diesem land leben und dass
diese menschen mit hilfe von von andere
länder auf den weg finden können
friedlich nebeneinander oder miteinander
zu leben das ist meine überzeugung und
das ist auch meine meinung meine ich
finde ich habe auch eine rolle in dieser
situation um ein bisschen in diese
richtung zu gehen damit meine kinder und
enkelkinder auch in diese in diesem land
bleiben und ihre nachbarn kennenlernen
und in frieden und sicherheit und
zusammenleben werden dann möchte ich mit
einem kommentar von tatiana philipp über
facebook die uns dort verfolgt enden
krieg ist nie eine lösung aber solange
es menschen gibt die miteinander auf
beiden seiten reden gibt es hoffnung
hoffnung auf frieden im nahen osten
insofern vielen vielen herzlichen dank
silli man ja ihr für die beteiligung für
den austausch für die diskussion danke
dass sie in der sendung waren und sascha
auch an sie liebe userinnen und user
zuhause das sie mit dabei waren bis zum
nächsten mal und ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen abend